[Music]
well we're going to learn an awful lot
about NAFTA and GATT and what's
happening in Chiapas and the
International power structure in the
two-part series we're going to have a
discussion with Mike Conroy Mike on Roy
is an economics professor at the
University of Texas Austin has been for
many years he's associate chairman of
the Economics Department and also he's a
director of the latin-american economic
studies program Mike's going to tell you
a lot about NAFTA that you hadn't heard
about before he is an expert in the area
of Latin America particularly Central
America has travelled in these areas
that we're talking about and he has been
on a lot of talk shows radio programs
and written articles about NAFTA and the
problems with it
so we're real fortunate to have you back
with us again thank you very the Chiapas
uprising is the one of the things that's
making a lot of headlines right now
what's now you've been down through that
area first of all what is the area like
geographically well Chiapas is
interestingly enough a geographical
continuation to the north extension to
the north of the mountains of Central
America people who visualize southern
and southeastern Mexico as they would
see Yucatan is flat with ancient
indigenous pyramids poking out of it in
fact would find if they went through
Oaxaca and into Chiapas that this is
very broken very mountainous heavily
wooded high pine forests mixed with
Intermountain valleys with many areas
that have only primitive roads going
through them and so if one were to
speculate on where within Mexico and
indigenous up writing rising might take
place that's tactically the most
interesting place for it to occur now
what is the connection here that's right
next to Guatemala you suppose they're
things going back and forth has been an
uprising of the Indians the indigenous
population for many years in Guatemala
well I think Frank that the Mexican
government would love us to believe that
this is nothing but a little outbreak on
the Mexican side of the indigenous
struggles that have occurred in
Guatemala as you know and as your
viewers will know Guatemala has had the
longest sustained indigenous revolt of
any of the Central American countries
going all the way back to 1953 and 1954
and many of the guerrilla forces working
in Guatemala have moved some of their
camps and bases of operations into the
very rugged area on the Mexican side and
there have been hundreds of thousands of
Guatemalan refugees on the Mexican side
but I don't think any of the evidence
that we have of the origins and growth
of the suppity the National Liberation
Front suggests that it has any ties
other than maybe some tactical ties to
the guerrilla forces in Guatemala
now this uprising this revolution revolt
whatever term you know to use seem to be
very highly organized and widespread so
this must have been something it just
wasn't very spontaneous well I think in
some levels it was very well organized
the anthropologists and others who have
worked down there over the last 10 to 15
years have been filling the electronic
mail with accounts of their encounters
with these people going back five to ten
years but on the other hand it isn't
nearly as well organized as the Central
American insurgencies were in that for
example more than half of the people who
were participants wearing the uniforms
wearing the red mask of the Sabbath east
front more than half of them had no
weapons at all many of them carried
wooden weapons with knives attached to
the end of them so it was a badly armed
and apparently poorly financed group but
very well organized you're right
their ability to take over in to hold
seven or eight towns for many days at
the beginning of January was an
indication of the low
of sophistication and organization that
they had and support of the people I
would assume also most of the people who
are in the area and talking to people in
the area say that there is considerable
support for their fundamental call for
their fundamental proposals there has
been as usually happens in the
mainstream media much more emphasis on
the one or two incidents where villagers
rounded up some of the Sabbath East us
who had few or poor arms and held them
in the plazas and beat them up while
waiting for the army to get there but
more of their in-depth reports that are
coming out now talk about the fact that
we're dealing with a situation which in
which fundamental injustice is
especially associated with the
indigenous population in Mexico are
breaking out into into an uprising I
think it's much too early to call it a
revolution it's clearly an uprising it's
clearly a revolt and it's something that
the Mexican government was totally
surprised by now I've read reports that
also heard on the National Public Radio
that they estimations of the Mexican
government that you know just a few
dozen people have been killed are very
very off base and that as many as maybe
a thousand people have been killed and
as the the Mexican army is still
carrying out air raids and artillery
attacks against villages and the
so-called guerrilla stronghold but at
this point three weeks after the
initiation of the uprising there are
whole zones of Chiapas where no
reporters can go and where there's
practically no communication in or out
so we don't really know I think you're
right in saying that most of the more
recent reports suggest and human rights
groups in Chiapas are beginning to build
documentation to show that the death
toll overall was considerably greater
than the official toe being quoted by
the Mexican government but we really
don't know and we won't know until third
parties until the Red Cross or until the
United Nations is able to get people
back into the mountains too many of
these villages that have been cut off
for the whole three weeks the poverty
there is incredible I understand this is
the equivalent in Mexico of our deep
south in the 1950s of our Appalachia of
our Ozarks these are terribly
impoverished remote rural areas who have
that have not been kept up with the
changes that have taken place in the
rest of Mexico Mexico and through very
difficult times in the early 1980s the
Mexican economy has been booming since
then but Chiapas isn't feeling that
Chiapas is also separated by the
indigenous factor and the gap within
Mexico remains enormously large for the
last 50 years and in pattern which is
similar to that of poor southerners
moving to the north when
industrialization took place in the
north of the United States after the
Second World War
poor Mexican Indians have been moving to
the north towards Puebla towards Mexico
City and further north looking for the
opportunity which has in fact grown much
more rapidly
close to the US border and of course
that's one of the reasons for the NAFTA
involvement in the whole question of
Chiapas before we get a NAFTA led I
understand that so tato
who's the leader of the insurrection was
saying that they just want education
they want opportunities they want food
they want a medical help these were the
normal things that people would want
they said that and here's a quote from a
statement that he had press conference
we're fed up with the misery and
humiliated amelie Asian inflicted upon
us by landlords the international timber
corporations which denude the last
remnants of our forests the corrupt
officials who have forgotten what the
word justice mean and they said NAFTA
was the last straw
well I think that it's more important to
emphasize the most fundamental sources
of their inequality in their poverty
which is the question that's referenced
there in terms of their relationship to
the landowners and the landlords these
are regions of Mexico the majority whose
population is indigenous its Native
American and just as the non Native
American population in the United States
forced Indians in this country off of
their land push them further and further
back into the mountains further out into
the plains these people have suffered
the same sort of difficulties at the
hands of the largely Latino or mestizo
dominant population within Mexico so
this is a portion of Mexico where the
indigenous dimension has also had a
tremendous link to economic and
political power and most fundamental
rights this is the part of Mexico where
people who come in and stake a claim to
land because the families who haven't
been living and been living there for
300 years
never got official titles to the land
are forcing them off of the land and so
their relationship with the local power
structure the local economic structure
the local political structure is one of
subordination because they're both poor
and inarticulate because many of them
don't speak Spanish many of them speak
only the indigenous languages and they
have been so isolated in the mountains
that there is no basis for them to
obtain justice within the Mexican system
so this method do you talk about a
taking the land away from people is
something that's been happening all over
the world for decades indeed but it's
interesting for a person like me who has
worked so much in Central America over
the last 15 years to see how similar the
problems of the sotell Indians in
southern Mexico are to the Mayan Indians
of Guatemala or of the people is in El
Salvador at the turn of the century when
they were forced off the land by the
Latino population and began the creation
of the social tensions which led to the
widespread civil war in El Salvador this
is a portion of Mexico which is far more
like Central America in terms of social
and economic and ethnic characteristics
than Mexicans want to have to face
that we had a couple of programs back
about 1978 1979 which people a one
person was talking about the uprising of
the people in the cities and towns
driving out their local mayor's and all
that and another program where the fella
actually spent time with some guerrillas
in I don't know it was Oaxaca where it
was super in this and they actually had
arms and they would carry out operations
against landlords and take some of the
and there are other areas of Mexico
where they've had uprisings like that to
how widespread is this type of thing
well it's at different levels and this
is the portion of Mexico where the left
political parties had greater strength
during the 1988 elections and led them
to take over certain municipalities when
the ruling party forced the models of
municipalities there were battles there
were many people killed in 1988 1989
Comey done is a town in that area that
is now back in the news because it's one
of the places that is serving as a base
for the Mexican army to go out and look
for the insurgents where the guerrillas
in the mountains so it isn't the first
time that the attention of the world has
been called to this kind of problem
within Mexico I think it's the
brilliance of the stroke that they would
start on January first on the first day
of NAFTA at a moment which is
particularly embarrassing to the Mexican
government that has made it a much more
important international and national
event than it would have been a month
earlier or than it might have been six
months later I noticed the US government
officials and also the Mexican
government officials said oh no it's
done everything doing NAFTA and yet like
you say they started the first day and
they admitted their interviews that yes
NAFTA is going to kill us what effect
will have to have on these people well
this is a good example that we'll
probably be coming back to as we talk
more about NAFTA in this discussion but
if you look at what's been happening in
Mexico for the last five or six years
since Mexico has take
this turn towards a neoliberal
conservative free-market development
policy it has drawn a tremendous amount
of foreign investment back into Mexico
it has led to the movement of many many
factories from the United States into
Mexico it has generated many jobs for
low wage and low productivity workers as
well as low wage high productivity
workers in Mexico but almost all of this
impact has taken place north of a line
that would be drawn through about Puebla
Puebla is a couple hundred kilometres
south of Mexico City so from Puebla on
north is where all of these new
factories have tended to be located and
the population to the south of that have
felt very little benefit from this new
growth process and what they see is that
the gap is growing even wider between
them and the rest of Mexico and the
political resentment about that is
something which feeds into the
fundamental question justice that
motivates these people with respect to
their indigenous rights their economic
rights their basic human rights and I
understand that NAFTA can have a
devastating effect on the small corn
farmers that's the key that they're most
concerned about and we've known from the
very beginning that one of the most
devastating potential impacts of NAFTA
was going to be its impact on the price
of corn for decades Mexico has in a
sense subsidized the smallest farmers in
the rural areas by keeping the price of
corn inside of Mexico somewhere between
40% and at times up to 70% higher than
the International price of corn because
Mexican corn prices were so high our big
corn farmers in this country have been
chomping at the bit to dump their extra
corn all that corn we've been storing
because of government programs in silos
here onto the Mexican market and that
will be great in terms of aiding our big
commercial farmers it's going to be
devastating for that large proportion of
corn farmers in Mexico who are
subsistence level farmers who can just
barely make it on the rural land
with corn some of which can be sold at
the subsidized prices into the Mexican
markets and one of the big surprises out
of the negotiation of the NAFTA treaty
was that the Mexicans did not demand
more leeway for slowing the rate at
which corn prices were going to fall in
fact they're going to fall very rapidly
and there's very little protection for
the Mexican corn producers against that
and the majority that impact is going to
be on those portions of Mexico where the
largest number of subsistence farmers
are and that's largely south of Mexico
City and that will drive them off the
land and they'll drive them off the land
drive them into the cities drive them
north drive them towards jobs in the
north drive them beyond the jobs which
may or may not be there in the north
towards the US border and there another
big problem they've announced that they
that the communal lands on the bigger
heroes will be sold instead of letting
the people work them that this is a
double blow for the poor farmers
throughout Mexico one of the most
important changes instituted by the
Salinas government in Mexico has been a
radical transformation of what's called
article 27 of the constitution article
27 was the portion of the Constitution
that created the communal farm system
and protected that farm system from
outside market pressures giving the land
to the people who have been farming it
for hundreds of years but saying you
cannot sell this land you have to use it
for you and your families and other
members of your community as a basis for
growing and prohibiting the sale of that
land the transformation of article 27
has now permitted the sale of that land
and what we're finding is that large
quantities of that land are being sold
to commercial farmers and hundreds of
thousands of peasant farmers are moving
off of the land because for the first
time they can gain a little bit of
income from selling their land even at
dirt cheap prices to finance their move
into the city where they have
hope of some better living terrible
situation it's going to be well I
remember a statement I forgive this
Minister of Interior one of the
bureaucrats and the Mexican government
saying that okay if you don't pass NAFTA
well if so that we can export more
easily to the United States
we'll just export our people well we may
have ended up with both things occurring
we we certainly ended up with NAFTA in
effect and can expect to see a dramatic
increase in exports of Mexico to the
United States but even some of the
studies that were done immediately
before the passage of NAFTA by people
who were supportive of NAFTA like Tom
Espen shade at the Urban Institute in
Washington Illustrated that the most
likely impact of NAFTA is to accelerate
the process by which Mexicans will move
across the border into the United States
and the reason for that is very
straightforward and relatively very
simple the impact on agriculture of
moving people out of the countryside
because who can no longer produce an
even a minimum system substances level
because of declining prices for
agricultural commodities and other
transformations one of the
transformations that people have talked
about in Mexico is parallel to what we
have to expect in this country large
numbers of small factories employing
large numbers of people are going to go
under as they now compete with the
transnational Giants that are moving
their production from the United States
into Mexico using much more capital
intensive processes using much less
labor and where is that labor going to
go well maybe into the service sector
economy also very likely that it will
look at the possibility of improving its
lot in life by moving north along this
line there were in the spotlight there
was an article about this and it it
indicated the chapter and page and a
line where it was talking about this
situation and was saying that there
provisions in NAFTA that within two
years there will not be any citizenship
requirement
laid upon people who will emigrate
now I haven't to read the rest of it
looked it up does this mean that this
doesn't mean like in in Europe there's
going to be a common citizenship does he
know as a matter of fact one of the
proposals early eliminated was the
notion that we would have free movement
of labour across the border what the
clause essentially says is that for
professionals for the better educated
for the already somewhat better off who
want to move from the United States in
New Mexico or Canada or from Canada and
us into Mexico the procedures which
previously were very restricted under
our general immigration law are going to
be greatly facilitated and they're going
to have an accelerated process for
normalizing their visas if they have a
firm willing to vouch for them saying
yes this is a especially needed
professional available here it only
applies to the professional class to
educated people and what many people
fear is that this will create a
substantial new brain drain out of
Mexico because we do have a significant
demand in this country for the Mexican
engineers and software scientists and
computer scientists and technicians who
are willing to work at significantly
lower wages than the people who are
being produced in our universities so
what we can expect is an increase in the
flow of technical personnel out of
Mexico because of that particular clause
it does not provide for free movement
back and forth across the border which
probably would have been a fairer way of
dealing with the gap that exists between
these two countries but obviously it
wouldn't have been politically
acceptable to the Congress well let's
talk about NAFTA you've done a lot of
radio programs and written articles
about the things in NAFTA I was just
utterly amazed at so much about NAFTA
that was never mentioned in the media
the regular media and even by Ross Perot
that fool who got
there let's talk about some of the
things that they didn't talk about in
the media I think the greatest success
of the pro NAFTA camp in orchestrating
the victory of moving it through the
Congress in the United States was their
ability to deflect attention from the
distributive impacts the NAFTA was
likely to have what they did is they
forced the debate and couch the debate
in terms of the overall benefits and the
overall losses probably but not
certainly going to be gained by each of
the three participants and even over
that there was tremendous debate but by
focusing so much of the debate on
whether there would be a 300 thousand
job gain or a 500 thousand job loss in
the United States after five years
because of NAFTA once they had focused
it very much on that particular debate
and commissioned lots of studies to
analyze that they deflected attention
from the fact that whether either is
going to be a small net gain in the
United States or a small net loss in the
United States there could be enormous
distributive implications that were not
brought out in any but some article that
a couple of colleagues and I did and
debates that we did but never in the
National debates at the at the top
levels I'll give you an example yeah
give an example Vice President Gore in
his debate with mr. Perot a debate which
really was the end of the line for the
anti-nafta group mr. Perot
was unfortunately so outrageous in ways
that were offensive not only to Mexicans
which are those of us who work in Mexico
and respect Mexico that he also
alienated many of the people including
Congress people I believe who might have
been willing to vote against NAFTA had
it not meant that they then had to
associate themselves with some of the
craziness of his of his presentations
but in that debate mr. Gore was arguing
there were going to be 200 or 300
thousand new jobs in the United States
mr. Perot was arguing there would be a
loss of millions of jobs well that
number the number a net gain of say
300,000 is an
that hides far more than it really
reveals because you could have as I
fully expect is going to occur the loss
of a million to a million and a half
jobs in the poorer portions of the
United States the south the Southwest
the southeast where so many of our
workers are low-wage low-skill low
education workers with whom Mexicans
compete very very effectively and if
there is a gain in jobs it's not going
to be in those areas so if you have a
million loss in the south and southeast
in the gain of 1 million two hundred
thousand in the north and northwest
that's a net gain of two hundred
thousand but the impact upon the
southeast and southwest is so totally
understated by saying there will be a
net gain of two hundred thousand jobs
that were we're focusing on the wrong
dimension it was easy for the
administration later to point out that
the economy gains about 11 million jobs
and loses about 10 million jobs overall
every year and that tends to be
relatively evenly distributed we're
talking about firms that close factories
that close down factories that move and
if effect removes out of Texas and goes
to the north that's a loss of jobs in
Texas and a gain of jobs in the north we
have about a ten million dollar churning
to a million person churning in our
labor force every year so in addition of
two hundred thousand is minuscule by
comparison but what it doesn't point out
is that we're going to have certain
industries the textile industry the
apparel industry the auto parts industry
the food processing industry are going
to be moving much more rapidly to Mexico
than they were from 1988 to 1990 to 1993
already we saw a massive movement of
those industries into Mexico and now
they have many reasons for accelerating
that process affecting specific regions
of the country chicken processing it's a
nasty business it happens to be one of
the businesses and the basis of which
mister Clinton built up the economy of
Arkansas but that part of the Arkansas
economy is now severely threatened by
the ability of those say
I'm patriotic us chicken packers to move
to Mexico and ship the chickens back
across the border now with no tariffs
chicken packing is an industry that
requires very close scrutiny by state
and local government for occupational
safety and environmental reasons to the
extent that people in places like North
Carolina and South Carolina and Arkansas
have been increasing the scrutiny of
Occupational Safety and environmental
conditions they're heading south where
where even though there may be good laws
in Mexico they're not enforced well in
the particular case of Occupational
Safety there aren't good laws in Mexico
there aren't good right-to-work laws
over or worker protection laws the
unionization is more often than not a
sweetheart Union that's associated with
the ruling party and the environmental
laws the the definition and the argument
about environmental law is a much more
complicated one than was dealt with in
the debate here in the country but even
there there are economic advantages of
fulfilling to the expectation of Mexican
law the environmental conditions down
there which give them an advantage even
over poor rural areas of Arkansas poor
rural areas of North Carolina so those
industries are the ones that are going
to be devastated and it is in a
situation where you take a 45 year old
semi-literate white woman sewing in a
factory in rural North Carolina that
you're going to say fine now that we
have a new job opening up in the
computer industry in the northwest we're
going to move you to it right up even if
we had programs to do it which we don't
even if we have programs to do with this
person isn't going to be qualified for
the jobs that are going to be created
and they wouldn't want to leave the
place where they live there probably
will work but what they're going to have
to do then is to pay the cost and the
consequences of this international
agreement which undermines their
lifetime of building expectations about
being able to live out their lives close
to their families in the communities
where they grew up but nobody talked
about those distributional impacts other
than a few of us and there was another
subject which you mentioned and that is
they talk about free trade and yet what
thousand pages of protectionism the
agreement right I think the best
characterization of it was by some Pro
NAFTA people saying there's really about
a hundred to 150 pages of free trade
treaty and then almost two thousand
pages of special interest legislation
protecting industry after industry in
the whole process Frank by which that
treaty was drafted where the Bush
administration brought together about
five hundred advisors ninety five
percent of whom came out of the
industries that were going to be
affected and allowed them to sit down
with a counterpart group in Mexico
saying right guys fight it out how are
you going to work out industry by
industry the best possible package for
you in your industry what this has given
us is a situation where there are
outrageous protectionist clauses in the
treaty as it was passed giving benefits
to those specific industries that were
able to push through what they most
wanted to do concrete example it is now
required that as part of the content
requirements for televisions that are
manufactured inside of the North
American Free Trade Agreement that one
specific component the general rules are
a certain proportion have to be made
locally but they specifically put in
saying that this picture screen has to
be manufactured in Mexico the US or
Canada well almost all of our pictures
tubes have been brought in from Japan
from Taiwan from Korea and what this is
is a tremendous boom to the US picture
tube manufacturing industry which is now
opening plants in Mexico to produce for
the newly protected North American
market for picture tubes for the
televisions that are competing there are
dozens of examples like that all the way
through the treaty and I tended to call
it and you've heard me on some of these
radio programs call it the North
American special protection agreement
rather than north american free trade
agreement and then in order to bribe
enough congress people to get them to
pass this thing they had to hand out
what the nation has said enough bribes
in the way of protections and other
special considerations something which
may cost the tax
as much 50 billion dollars just to get
this thing passed it was ironic because
a lot of the special deals that were cut
during the last three or four days of
negotiation were things that in fact
violated the north american free trade
agreement concrete example the sugar
industry in Cal in Florida and in
Colorado the sugarcane industry in
Florida the sugar beet industry in
Colorado were adamantly opposed to the
free trade agreement because they fully
expected that Mexico would dump large
quantities of sugar into the US at
substantially lower prices and then
Mexico would replace its sugar with
sugar they could get relatively easily
from Cuba
so this Cuban connection was something
that the sugar industry was hollering
and screaming about well one of the
things that mr. Clinton agreed to even
though it technically requires a
modification of the treaty that the
Canadians and the Mexicans were willing
to overlook was to say to the Florida
and Colorado sugar producers we are
simply going to not follow the terms
that are specified in the treaty for a
minimum of five years and then only
phase in very slowly what changes are
going to be phased in for the sugar
industry even though the sugar industry
Clause was quite different in the treaty
so this was supposed to be fast-track
this was supposed to be yes or no on the
treaty as it was and when it came down
to getting the last few votes they made
changes in the treaty by agreeing
somehow to block the imports of sugar
for another five years protecting that
special industry and simultaneously
calming the fears of the Cuban American
community in Miami that Cuban sugar was
going to indirectly come in through
Mexico to me one of the most absolutely
censored never mentioned in any of the
news broadcasts I ever heard or any of
the debates and that is the absolute
could be the destruction of economic and
democracy or even our democracy and
that's these resolution dispute panels
and tribunals these secret things that
were are in the treaty not talked about
can you tell us about those well they
still have to be formulated one of the
things you got to realize about the free
trade agreement was
in order to get it through and in order
to get it through without having to take
the time to work out all of the details
that for example the European community
took 28 years to work out the creation
and staffing and organization of all
these panels the treaty simply says
there will be a resolution dispute panel
and it provides some minimum detail on
how one has to approach these if there
is a dispute but as things stand right
now if you were a small producer of a
product in Central Texas in the
northeastern United States in the
northwestern United States and suddenly
found yourself being inundated by
Canadian or Mexican products that you
were certain they were dumping into our
markets the dispute mechanism doesn't
exist
it isn't clear who you go to in order to
call for some new intervention to stop
that dumping and gradually they're going
to be created but they don't even have
bylaws it doesn't we don't know what the
composition is going to be we don't know
how they're going to be named but the
most important details of our trading
relations among these three countries
are going to be resolved by these panels
and we don't know yet who is going to
form them how they're going to be formed
what participation if any we will have
democratically in them other than the
fact that presumably there's going to
have to be some agreement between the
ruling administrations in all three
countries about their composition at
some point in time ladies it is a an
elimination of much of the authority
that Congress previously had for making
these determinations and making these
decisions and passing them on to
international tribunals over which we we
can't even claim to know how we're going
to exercise some control because we
don't know what the composition of them
or their structure is going to be now
the multinational monitor has a whole
edition on NAFTA and it has one two
pages on on these tribunals and it talks
about you know all the procedure to go
about and mainly it's to keep the
ordinary person or
public interest groups keep their noses
out of the situation but as I understand
it these tribunals would have the
authority to an effect strike down any
local state or national law which the
companies or the national governments
claim will be an impediment to trade and
some of these things have already under
GATT for instance have been challenged
and the for instance they forced
cigarettes on Thailand Thailand was
wanting to was concerned about the
health of their people and so they said
okay we're not going to import
cigarettes but the tribunal the gas
people said no you got it that's an
impediment trade a barrier trade and so
now Thailand has to take cigarettes and
so they could conceivably strike them
down in the sense that I know they can
find countries or they can have
retribution with the other trading
partners against that particular country
that has this what they consider an
offense and it's all done in secret by
these panels which are you know
pro-business to start out with this can
have far-reaching consequences for
democracy well I think it where I find
it more most threatening has to do with
the kind of grassroots democracy that in
this country for example has been the
strongest basis for the evolution and
growth of the environmental movement
it's a very severe threat to the ability
of unions to negotiate improve
conditions for their own workers it's a
serious threat to the fundamental rules
and what we're really talking about here
are the rules that we use for allowing
goods to cross the border what NAFTA
does for these three countries what gap
does for the world and we can talk about
GATT later because it's actually a
little more frightening with get what
nefta does for these three countries is
sets a basic set of ground rules that
will be abided by by all three partners
minimizing the conditions on
which you can stop the movement of a
product from one country to another a
part of the ploy that's been used is to
say if you're against GATT you're
obviously a protectionist and they grew
protectionist or something wrong with
you that even that hasn't been dealt
with appropriately we deliberately
choose to protect ourselves this week
the Clinton administration is arguing in
China that we are going to protect
ourselves from products produced by
prison labor in Chinese prisons yeah we
have prison labor here in the United
States we have prison labor in this
country and we're not necessarily
talking about the implications yeah but
we do choose not to allow products that
have certain characteristics to cross
the border we don't allow products that
have certain kinds of residue chemicals
on them to cross the border when we talk
about GATT a little bit later that's a
very critical point in get that is
exactly along lines of what you're
talking about we will not be able to
legislate regulations in the state of
Texas or in the United States or if we
want it in the City of Austin different
from the rules that are set up by this
international tribunal in order to
restrict the flow of Mexican or Canadian
products into Texas or into Austin now
you might say that's fine that increases
the flow of goods but for years the
environmental movement in California for
example they've been way ahead of the
environmental movement nationwide and
for their own reasons Californians have
required higher levels of environmental
controls and automobiles that's not
going to be allowed any longer yeah
communities and other states have
required
higher levels of inspection of products
crossing from one state to another
that's not going to be allowed either
because if a product goes from Mexico
into Arizona and is stopped at the
border of California is as crossing from
Arizona that will be interpreted as a
restraint on trade from Mexico so we are
going to find ourselves with this
homogenizing of regulations not
necessarily at the level that we as a
nation or we as a state or we as a city
or we as a county might choose to use
for ourselves we're going to be
bound by these internationally
homogeneous groups if it's difficult
enough for us now to get Congress to
pass in a new environmental control law
imagine how difficult it's going to be
for us to have to convince the Congress
and then convince the Congress to go to
the international tribunal and then to
get people in Canada and Mexico also to
organize to go to the international
tribunal to make one major or one minor
change in environmental regulations
that's the way in which our grassroots
ability to affect what's happening
around us is seriously undercut there's
another thing that hadn't been talked
about in the media or just mentioned
perhaps so get in passing that's the
Regional Development Bank which as I
understand is supposed to help get this
thing started and to build
infrastructure and to help clean up the
mess the maquiladoras have left can you
tell us about that
well one of the concerns especially
raised by some courageous Hispanic
legislators statement flawed is
especially out of California was almost
single-handedly responsible for this was
a concern that much of the burden of the
adjustment much of the burden of the
additional cost much of the burden of
the further deterioration of the US
Mexican border it was going to be borne
by the Hispanic population in this area
and they insisted on some sort of a
program it ultimately is going to be
called the North American Development
Bank in ADB as a basis for providing the
loans needed to fund the activities of
adjusting but this raises the much
bigger question that Bank was agreed to
in principle with an initial
capitalization of about 250 million
dollars yeah that is a drop in the
bucket in terms of the overall
adjustment costs that these three
nations are going to face let me give
you a counter example there's only been
one successful long-term integration of
economies similar to what we're trying
to do with NAFTA and that's the European
community
now they started in 1958 and only in
1992 what is that
34 years later finally joined all of
their programs together and created what
was a complete European Union in fact
they call themselves now the European
Union which allows free flow of goods
free flow of capital free flow of people
across all the boundaries of these
countries but look what they've had to
do in order to adjust to in assist
countries to adjust to it from the very
beginning they recognize that we're
going to be regions negatively affected
workers put out of work factories closed
down and so they created two major
European programs the European
Development Fund and the European Social
Fund the European Development Fund is
used to assist those communities that
lose their factories to search for
another factory to provide some
subsidies the location of a new factory
to develop a new industry to find new
technology to create the jobs so that
people can get back to work after the
factory closes because it moves from
Germany to Spain or from Spain to
Germany within the European Union now 34
years later they have continued to
increase every year the amount they
spend on those adjustment programs they
are spending in 1993-94 in their fiscal
year more than eight billion dollars 34
years into the adjustment programme they
have spent a total of hundreds of
billions of dollars helping communities
adjust to all of the impacts that the
integration is designed to have we
recognise that we're supposed to have
significant changes in our economies
we're supposed to get a leaner and
meaner US economy leaner and fat or
fatter and meaner Mexican economy
Canadian economy which is more
rationalized with this means closing
factories and opening plans it means
closing some jobs down retraining people
here we have not created anything other
than this tiny little 250 million dollar
border development bank as a basis for
adjustment it's nothing as an economist
now what's the difference with a
economic union a European Union but with
joining of people like France
Germany with economies like Italy and
Spain but the United States and Canada
joining us what's in fact a third world
country or at least maybe a half a third
world country almost a little bit more
than that New Mexico that's an enormous
gap right there's never been a
successful economic integration between
countries with as large a gap is exist
between the United States and Mexico the
way the administration countered that
suggestion was for the early trade
negotiator Carla Hills as well as
president Salinas when he visited here
in Austin two years ago saying yes but
in the European Union the gap between
West Germany and Portugal was about the
same as the gap between Mexico and the
United States it was a very good
suggestion was a good try but it was
wrong first of all because it wasn't
just Portugal joining with West Germany
in 1986 which is the last major
expansion of the European Union European
Economic Community
it was Spain and Portugal joining 11
other nations and when you compare the
standard of living in Spain and Portugal
to the average standard of living in 11
other nations they had already about 60%
of the standard of living of the rest
and so the gap was between one that were
one region it was 60 percent of the
whole and others at various levels the
Mexican economy compared to the US and
Canadian economies has a standard of
living and the most favorable terms of
analysis and we did the analysis here at
Texas and in the most favorable terms
about 23 to 24 percent of the level of
development of the United States and
Canada
we've never had a successful integration
of economies like that so we should
expect really serious changes larger
changes than they were expecting in the
European Economic Community
therefore we should expect to need
greater adjustment funds and these are
some of the arguments that mr. Perot
should have been using and a more
reasonable basis in his debate with the
Vice President Gore but he got
distracted what about the some of the
perhaps less significant things but
still things that could happen like the
safety and lie
sensing requirements of trucks and
drivers coming across and the there was
a big article here in Austin Statesman
American Statesman about the drug lords
buying up trucking lines and warehouses
on the Mexican border because all the
goodies they can now come in much more
easily because of NAFTA
if we aren't able to deal with our drug
problem other than by building some sort
of an anti drug barrier at that border
NAFTA is going to lessen our ability to
control it if the only way we can keep
drugs out is to stop them from crossing
the border with these radar balloons and
with aircraft chasing aircraft and with
all the high-tech stuff along the ground
NAFTA is going to make it much easier to
get drugs across not because necessarily
the drug lords are buying trucking lines
but because the flow of traffic is going
to double and triple and because in
order to get that traffic across the
bridges and the roads that we have right
now everyone is saying we have to make
the customs more efficient we have to
inspect fewer of the trucks we have to
have better paperwork we have to trust
more the stuff coming across have
factory have trucks closed up as they
leave the factory and I've reopened
until they get to a factory up here in
the north all of that is going to
increase the ability of diligent drug
traffickers to move large quantities of
drugs across the border much more easily
than they have in the past alternatively
we could increase the amount of
surveillance and put whole divisions of
the military down along the border as
certain political candidates are now
proposing stop every truck for a half an
hour to two hours unload it inspected
for drugs load it up and move it across
again but the howls and screams that
you'll get from the business people
because of the slowing down of the
crossing of the border will make that
impossible it is going to be easier to
cross the border that means it can be
easier for drugs to cross the border but
that's also simply a reflection of the
fact that the solution to our drug
problem is not stopping the movement of
drugs across the border it's producing
the demand and changing the focus in
this country which changing the social
conditions which lead people to turn to
drugs
another category of concern and
contention or licensing of professionals
now can the Mexicans who want to come up
here for instance and be doctors or
dentists or lawyers can they go to one
of these tribunals and say hey the
requirements for getting a license to
practice in the United States are too
onerous it's a restraint of trade and so
our requirements will have to be
lessened to meet those there is going to
be some harmonization of that but I'm
actually less concerned about that than
I am about many other characteristics of
it
in fact the quality of the training of
Mexican professionals is very very high
I don't think we need to worry about the
quality of the physicians that come out
of the Mexican schools of medicine
principal reason that people will go to
Mexican just Mexico to study medicine
rather than stay in the United States is
the American Medical Association
restricts the supply of doctors in order
to keep doctors wages high by lessening
the number of people or limiting the
number of people and getting in medical
schools and there are lots of very very
good people who then turn to Mexico and
other countries for their training more
importantly the quality of the training
makes these people very very competitive
with workers in the United States and if
they can't find ways of getting into the
United States to work under wage scales
that are typical of the United States
they will go to work in factories in
Mexico where they work for substantially
less in the software industry in the
computer industry in the design industry
in the advertising industry and in
biomedical industries that's likely to
take place I'm not worried about the
quality of the workers coming across
what I'm worried about is that the fact
that you have such very high
productivity high quality workers in
Mexico who because of a variety of
conditions in their labor markets work
for half or less of what comfortable
people work for in the United States I
heard one person say Doug calendar our
friend Doug Keller said he thought that
the passage of NAFTA was Bill Clinton's
big and first litmus test with the
American power structure and ruling
class that even though he could be
wishy-washy and a wimp and
compromise so much on things that might
affect the people they were really
playing hardball to get this thing
passed this was a supremely important
thing
well when David Rockefeller comes on TV
and starts talking about it you know
that they're really concerned I think
that there's no question that
conservative business interests and
especially the transnational corporate
interests wanted NAFTA very very badly
and the fact of the matter is that mr.
Clinton's coalition was a coalition of
labor environmentalists women minorities
and conservative Democratic business
interests the one thing which the
conservative Democratic business
interests demanded of him as a
precondition for their support in his
election was his support of NAFTA and it
is something which is going to tear that
coalition apart to some extent and has
already torn the coalition apart the
severance of his ties with labor is
going to be costly to him later on when
he wants their support on other issues
but what it was was a moment in which
the business community the transnational
business community really represented by
and led by Secretary of Treasury Benson
it was the most Pro NAFTA member in the
whole Clinton administration pushed us
through as something which they
absolutely had to do if they didn't want
to completely alienate the business
community and it makes sense that the
business community would push for it
this free trade agreement is a big
business free trade agreement it's a
free trade agreement which is going to
hurt small business it's going to hurt
local business it's very very good for
those corporations that are large enough
to produce in both places to market in
both places to combine their production
facilities so that components are made
in Mexico components are made in the
United States assembly takes place one
work place or another and then they ship
to the rest of the world little firms
can't do that so it's the big firms that
gain a significant advantage from
getting this new access to Mexican labor
much more important than getting new
access to Mexican markets because the
Mexican market relative to the US market
is still only 10 or 15 percent of the US
market so what they really wanted access
to was Mexican regulations Mexican labor
in the real reason that unions really
to oppose it had no choice but to oppose
it was that this gives every major
factory every major firm in every labor
union negotiation the ability to say if
you don't give us the concessions that
we want you can threaten the strike all
you want all we're going to do is more
Factory in Mexico we're going to have a
gradual overall lowering of wages in the
united states of laboring conditions of
the ability of unions to negotiate
because of that constant threat of being
able to move a factory into mexico or
you can find high quality high
productivity low-wage workers to replace
any group of workers in this country so
it looks like the conditionally american
standard living is going to worsen and
worse and worse at a time when it's
already at the lowest level in decades
now the liberalisation that has taken
place under reagan and bush has already
forced the real earnings of families in
this country down for almost 20 years
straight it began in 1973 and it's
continued coming down what it'll
certainly do is it will eliminate some
of the possibilities we would have had
for hire stand it's a living it isn't
going to push us wages suddenly to the
level of mexican wages but it's going to
eliminate many of the opportunities that
we might have had to raise wages in this
country more importantly and this i
think is is the bottom line argument for
me in terms of nafta it gives all the
wrong signals to firms that use american
workers there are two alternative future
roads that american industry could
follow it could follow the road that the
Europeans and the Japanese have been
following which is a high road high
productivity high skill levels enabling
them to pay high wages for the
production of world-class goods and the
good safety net social services with a
good set of social services paid for out
of that high level of productivity in
the taxation that comes off of it there
is another road which I call the low
road and that's the road of saying we
can also produce the same products using
labor-intensive processes with low
productivity low-skilled workers where
rather than pay for high productivity
workers when we have to train and retain
and keep and work with using the latest
of high-tech machinery we're going to go
with a low-tech solution and we're going
to out-compete the Mexicans we're going
to out-compete the Koreans we're going
to out-compete the Brazilians by getting
our wage costs down even lower and using
what are essentially third-world
production processes by opening the door
to Mexico we're allowing many more US
firms to say I can now supply the US
market using the low road strategy
whereas previously they would have given
much more serious thought to taking the
high road strategy investing in their
workers raising their productivity and
being able to pay higher wages in our
last alternative use program we dwelt at
length with NAFTA and particularly
covering all the aspects of it that were
not covered by the regular media we were
talking with Mike Conroy's an economics
professor at the University of Texas at
Austin director of the latin-american
economic studies program and he's the
associate chairman of the Economics
Department this time we're going to talk
about the Big Daddy of Gap that I saw it
stated somewhere is that if you love if
you like NAFTA you love GATT because get
the general agreement on tariffs and
trade is something which is could be
even much more devastating than NAFTA
but before we have our interview here
are some news stories from the
alternative press well in one of the
biggest fraud cases in history it was
announced by the New York Times on
October the 21st the Prudential agrees
to pay investors for fraud losses at
least 371 million dollars that 400,000
individuals were affected by this court
decision it appeared that Prudential
securities which is a unit of Prudential
Insurance Company of America has been
facing legal claims from people all over
the country investors who said that the
firm systematically cheated them in the
sell of more than eight hundred billion
dollars of limited partnerships that
invested in oil gas real estate at
cetera most of the investors were
assured that these were safe
conservative secure investments in many
cases they weren't and they were told of
tremendously lucrative returns that
would accrue from this investment that
didn't materialize well the security
Exchange Commission ruled that the
advertisements or the claims that
Prudential securities made to its
customers was simply fraudulently they
simply lied systematically all over the
country and thus forced them to pay back
investors millions of dollars for these
fraudulent claims they also charged the
SC SEC widespread securities law
violations at all nine Prudential branch
offices failing to live up through terms
of a 1986 settlement with the SEC on
fraud charges and severe legal and
compliance problems with a whole lot of
different issues I think it should be
pointed out so this is not a
fly-by-night organization we're talking
about Prudential is one of the core
Rockefeller establishment financial
institutions and has been for years and
years and years it always kind of galls
me to see some of these big corporate
executives the saying well now all these
bad things that you see about the
capitalist corporations those are just
the smaller medium-sized corporations
the big ones we we are good corporate
citizens we wouldn't stoop to that well
we found out what happens with
Prudential and we see a Prudential also
had it as chairman of the board
former chairman the board George ball
who was one of the most significant men
than the United States power structure
and has been for years you ever heard of
Peru care well that's Prudential
Insurance they're going to be one of the
big recipients of the largesse of
Clinton's health care program
and this I guess was only that was the
second largest payout of because of
fraud the other one was till Birnam
Drexel umbehr so you've got to be
careful whether it's a big company or a
little company they can't you just can't
say well we're an established old
company they'll rip your drawers off
just as fast as some of the smaller
companies if Bill and Hillary Clinton
are serious about slashing US health
care costs expect to top one trillion by
next year they should re-examine
Washington's love affair with the
tobacco industry each year smoking
related diseases are responsible for 21
billion dollars in direct health care
costs according to the congressional
office of Technology Assessment another
47 billion in unnecessary cost are due
to lost productivity and lost earnings
associated with smoking far from acting
to curb these costs let alone to so to
slow a cigarette related death toll of
nearly 500,000 Americans per year
Congress has actively aided the tobacco
industry Capitol Hill has excluded
cigarette from cigarettes from the
Consumer Product Safety Act and the fair
labeling and packaging act lawmakers
have also existed exempted tobacco from
the Toxic Substances Act even though a
cigarette has more cyanide than was
found in those tainted Chilean grapes
that everyone was so worried about a few
years back I saw a an analysis of what
was in cigarettes and they it was
indicated that the cigarettes not only
had benzene but it also had DDT and
phosgene and phosgene as people probably
know is nerve gas so that actually when
you're taking a big old long puff of
that cancer stick that you're actually
in hailing this nerve gas and carrying
out chemical warfare against your own
body in the last few years Congress has
killed are simply ignored at least 10
anti-smoking legislative initiatives the
White House has been no better Ronald
Reagan and George Bush waged a costly
war on drugs this despite studies
showing that illegal drugs were
connected to the dead
of 19,000 96 Americans last year 126th
the number that were killed by
cigarettes and while the Reagan and Bush
administration's were waging their war
against drug pushers in Colombia they
were also actively pressuring other
governments especially in Asia to open
their markets to US tobacco products the
new issue of world smoking and health a
publication of the American Cancer
Society looks at why the White House and
Capitol Hill continued to guarantee
tobacco special place as the only
mass-marketed consumer product that
causes widespread death and disease when
used as intended the results are not
surprising the tobacco lobby has bought
out our elected politicians and the
bribes are getting bigger industry
contributions to incumbent US senators
through 1991 in the first half of 1992
190 192 percent over the contributions
made during all of the 1987-88 campaign
cycle according to one article
well Clinton change things don't hold
your breath several top White House
advisors including Mickey Kantor the
president's former campaign manager and
current US Trade Representative have
close ties to the tobacco industry in
these times an earlier edition said that
there were they pumped 25 point seven
million dollars into the campaigns of
1991 in 1992 and the largest amounts of
this of this money went to the key
members of the committee's handling the
health reform legislation we'll have
more news later let's turn now to our
interview with Mike Conroy economics
professor at the University of Texas
about GATT now Mike we've had to get
since I remember people talking about it
in the in the late 40s early 50s why is
there such a big to-do about GATT
well the general agreement on tariffs
and trade which people think about as a
treaty agreement is in fact a whole
organization it's a world organization
that focuses on tariffs and trade and it
has had as its goal since the end of the
Second World War
eliminating all barriers to the movement
of goods across boundaries of countries
and it's come back into our focus since
1986 when the latest round of
negotiations was begun it happened to be
started in Buda why and so it's been
called it would a round of GATT and what
they're attempting to do is to further
reduce tariffs below the levels that
earlier negotiations had gotten them to
and clarifying all kinds of new areas
that previously weren't covered by GATT
including trade in services intellectual
property rights a whole variety of
issues that previously weren't taken any
consideration the new GATT agreement
which emerged from negotiations in
Geneva where it's headquartered on
December 15th is not what people had
hoped it would be in the end because it
isn't a complete agreement it is still
riddled with compromises and concessions
and special interests but if it's
implemented it will take us dramatically
closer to a world in which not only are
there few barriers between countries in
terms of the flows of goods and services
but much less ability on the part of
countries to control the movement of
goods across their borders and therefore
much less ability on the part of
countries to organize their own economic
development processes but don't we have
two things going here we talked mostly
about countries when we talk I say we
the media and the government when they
talk about trade but trade is carried on
by corporations molten hi
corporations and I guess I've seen the
most I was carried on by I think about
500 multinational corporations and I've
also seen figures that up to 50% maybe
even more than 50% of the trade is not
trade from one country to the next
but it's intra company trade it's a
company trading with the city Aires etc
so what are we really talking about here
what we're talking about here plain and
simple is an attempt by the largest
corporations of the world who have
little or no allegiance to a single
nation to eliminate it's their attempt
to eliminate the last barriers that they
have to face for the movement of their
goods back and forth across borders in
the elimination of a wide range of
regulatory policies of Industry subsidy
policies of protection policies and
alcala protectionist policies and I call
the protection policies because we have
a legitimate right to some protection of
our national interests elimination of
those protection policies so that they
have an absolutely clear and open
playing field on which to operate the
trade you're absolutely correct is
dominated by a small number of very
large corporations and the vast majority
of the world's trade doesn't pass
through what we call free markets it
isn't that you go out and find out what
the price is in eight or ten different
international markets for a commodity
get the cheapest one and bring it across
where it's recorded as it crosses the
border at its real market value the vast
majority of trade takes place within
corporations where one subsidiary of a
company sends a product to another
subsidiary of a company and the prices
that are charged for that transaction
have nothing whatsoever to do with free
market prices unless it's absolutely
cool incidental the prices which are
charged in this process called transfer
pricing something which congressman Jake
pickle just began to scratch at during
his last year
1/2 in the Congress transfer pricing
allows firms to put whatever price they
want on the commodity that they move
from one country to another and by
setting their prices they can not only
avoid taxes in the higher taxing country
but they can have enormous impacts upon
the terms of trade upon the value of
imports and the value of exports of the
countries with whom they're working
avoiding virtually any governmental
control over the movement of wealth
within these corporations that's why
that is so important to the global elite
of corporations because it reduces
dramatically the limited barriers that
still exist to their total operation on
a global scale
without much control at any local level
now there's something else is happening
- and that is the division of the world
by the big guys into basically three
areas the economic the European Union
the Western Hemisphere and the Asian Rim
with Africa I guess being tossed in
there for whoever wants it but now how
does this fit into the GATT type of
structure well I think the most
important force would then get is
simpler than that it's the group of
seven the seven largest industrial
democracies they call them seven largest
industrial countries the United States
Great Britain France Italy Canada Japan
Germany and Germany okay
those seven countries effectively
account for more than sixty percent of
world trade just the trade among
themselves and so one of the things that
we saw taking place during the closing
days of the negotiation of this last
round of the GATT treaty was tremendous
out cries coming from other countries
around the world saying wait a second
you can't do that
that wasn't part of what we did in our
negotiations and they essentially said
wait a second just forget it guys we're
talking to one another and the final
round of negotiations was between the
French and the United States
and the Germans and the Japanese over
what concessions they were willing to
make because there is were the most
important markets in this process and it
really does separate them out from the
rest of the world so you really have a
group of seven and the rest of the world
and this particular round of agreements
is going to be most beneficial for the
group of seven but the vast majority of
other nations around the world are going
to have to go along with it otherwise
they get excluded and get isolated
because they have to have access to the
markets of the group of seven and unless
they abide by the GATT treaties they're
not going to get that access when out as
I understand it these group of seven
countries still if we just talk about
countries as traitors they still trade
mainly among themselves that's great
although there is some north-south trade
that's great but now what are they are
they setting up these the division of
these three areas of the world to so
that they can vertically geographically
exploit the the raw material in all and
the cheap labor in these areas that they
will dominate but I'd I tend to think
that what we have are different stages
in the movement towards a single goal
that they have set out the single goal
they've set out is to have no barriers
whatsoever inhibiting their ability to
go into Irian Java and take the minerals
out of aerion Java utilizing very low
wage and ship them to anywhere in the
group of seven or to go into newly
independent newly democratized South
Africa and to exploit that particular
market selling their products as well as
bringing the minerals and other
resources out they want access to those
markets but those aren't the really
dominant markets it's the trade among
these countries you're correct in saying
but as steps towards get in to some
extent as goads to the creation of GATT
and as fallbacks in case GATT didn't go
through
you had the creation of the European
community now the creation of the north
american free trade agreement and it's
possible extension to other countries in
the Western Hemisphere and the creation
of a Pacific Rim trading group where
Japan is negotiating special trading
relationships with Thailand Korea
Hong Taiwan in its sphere of dominance
but it's really a much more complicated
world than one which we've broken into
those three those three groups if there
hadn't been agreement reached on GATT
the Europeans were perfectly comfortable
emphasizing over the course of the next
10 to 15 years
the further integration of the European
community and its protection from the
rest of the world had it not gone
through NAFTA would have become the
basis for the expansion of US markets
and us access to Latin America and Japan
would have further establish special
trading relationships but all of these
individual trading relationships now
will be superseded by GATT because gas
rules are even more general gas rules
are even more profound gets rules are
common across all of these regions and
in theory at least get will break down
some of the protectionism that still
remains between NAFTA and the European
community or between NAFTA and Japan
isn't this also going to solidify or put
in concrete the existing economic
development and trade relationships
because the United States or Germany
grew behind protection Airi walls the
united states industrialized behind high
tariffs and so did Korea and Japan and
Taiwan so this means that the
international power structure is going
to make sure that they're going to be no
more of these upstarts that could maybe
challenge their hegemony well that's a
that's a very insightful comment Frank
and one that we haven't seen too much in
the press what get does among other
things is it eliminates many of the
developmental tools that countries have
successfully used in the past to go from
raw material exporters to industrial
giants the best example of that I think
is Brazil Brazil has a tremendous amount
of schizophrenia around its
participation in GATT because Brazil is
a very large country with mineral wealth
and industrial wealth and its own
technology and so forth
it's also taken advantage of a
deliberate process of violating patent
laws pirating software of copying
computers it's been an outcast but it
may well have been the best strategy for
Brazil not to sign copyright laws not to
to sign new agreements on the protection
of intellectual property rights
worldwide because then it has to start
paying licensing fees for things that it
gets from other parts of the world which
right now it can simply copy used to be
we would claim that it's just those
communist countries over there that are
copying our technology and not paying
paying for the patents well in fact it
turns out that the biggest copiers of
software the biggest imitators of
computer chips the biggest non legal or
illegal copying comes out of places like
Taiwan Mexico and Brazil and one of the
things are going to have to give up is a
process under this GATT agreement is
their ability to do that with some
impunity they're going to have to
eliminate the subsidies that they give
to the development of specific
industries here's a concrete example
what's the model which is being used now
as the example that the poor countries
of Latin America and Africa should
pursue as a basis for developing a high
standard of living
it's the Asian model it's the mini
dragon model of Korea Taiwan Singapore
and Hong Kong and the theory is that
that's a free market model but as soon
as you start looking at what those
countries did in the 1960s and 1970s in
order to go from being relatively
primitive countries to very advanced
industrial countries you find it wasn't
the free market model it was rather a
very deliberate set of government
programs in coordination with the
largest industries creating local
monopolies protecting them from
international competition demanding that
they export their products demanding
that they become internationally
competitive and conditioning the
continuation of government support on
the evidence that these industries were
internationally competitive that's not
the free market model that's a very
deliberate developmental model those
program
would not be allowed under get so like
you say it's the countries that have
already achieved significant levels of
industrialization saying okay guys
nobody else should copy the policies
which we utilized in order to develop to
this level and as a matter of fact what
you should do is open all your borders
to the products which we can now export
and simply ship us your raw materials
ship us your labor allow us to invest
for little assembly plans in your
countries when we need cheap labor to
ship back into the global markets and it
is in a sense and attempt on the part of
the already powerful nations to
eliminate the future ability of Brazil
or of Mexico or of Colombia or of
Indonesia to implement policies which
would make them serious industrial
threats in the near future this will
also entrench some of the worst
dictatorships and also prevent any
indigenous or popular uprisings to to
take place I would think well I'm not
certain that I see that the direct link
between GATT and the dictatorships other
than the fact that international or
transnational capital doesn't like the
uncertainty of democracy it's very hard
to impose austerity on a country under
democratic conditions the terrible
turmoils of Russia and the other
republics of the former Soviet Union
where they're trying to transform their
economy and their political system at
the same time is one illustration of it
a better illustration is the fact that
Chile's economy performed much better
from the point of view international
bankers when General Pinochet was in
charge when he could impose austerity
clamp down on inflation and eliminate
labor unions and Chile's economy boom
during that period because of the
political control the countries like
Korea with its political control
Singapore with its political control
anti-democratic controls Taiwan which is
not a very democratic place have used
political controls as a basis for their
rapid economic development and if the
giant corporations that are now
reinforced through GATT gain more
political power than your right that
probably is anti-democratic the theory
of course and this is all based on
theory of free trade and
between free trade and democratization
the theory says free trade will help to
bolster the more economic growth and
more economic growth means more
democracy and so forth but if we look
for cases indicating much of the
concrete dimensions of that theory
they're hard to find
now you mentioned free trade now this
goes back into theory to the great
economist David Ricardo centuries ago
and you're here all the time or your
free trader or protectionist it's almost
like a McCarthyism that you if you're
not for free trade you're just a bad bad
person what does free trade actually
mean nowadays back in Ricardo's air it
meant that one country would do what it
could do best another country would do
what it could do best and then they
would trade and everybody would benefit
David Ricardo talked in terms of a
principle of comparative advantage and
that principle of comparative advantage
is the tool that we use for teaching our
undergraduate economics students of
meaning in the advantages of free trade
but as the New York Times was forced to
admit on a in a front-page story last
December right about the time the gap
treaty was was it to be signed that
here's a primer on free trade and it got
into the third paragraph of its premier
on free trade and it said but you've got
to admit that no economist can give us
concrete examples of the notion that
free trade will necessarily raise the
standard of living of all of those who
participate in it we do know the free
trade raises the standard of living of
those who are more powerful more
advanced more developed in a free
trading relationship what's more
difficult to demonstrate is that it
significantly improves the lot of those
who are less powerful who are smaller
who don't have the same economic cloud
or political cloud in the global
economic system truth of the matter is
there is no country in the world that
practices free trade second true that I
think we have to recognize is that the
Reagan and Bush administration's claimed
that their target was for us to be the
leading nation in terms of free trade
one of the problems
got into by the end of the Reagan period
in and through the Bush administration
was that we suddenly found that here we
were proclaiming the principles of free
trade and acting as though we wanted to
push the principles of free trade and
most of our trading partners thought we
were crazy Japanese are free traders the
Germans aren't free traders the British
are Margaret Thatcher might have been
the British government policy was not
the French are not free traders the
Canadians may be closer or at least they
were closer under Mulroney but then
Mulroney's whole party disappeared after
he signed the North American Free Trade
Agreement and on behalf of Canada all of
our trading partners practice one level
or another of protection and it's very
sophisticated protection it's not just
tariff barriers it's a wide array of
non-tariff barriers the Japan bashing
that takes place in this country ought
to be recognized as statements that say
Japan is not a free trader the world
markets in which we function are not
free markets so the argument from the
very large corporations is GATT will
move us towards more free markets and
force us all to be more free marketeers
and allow us to have more efficient
trading relations and you get these
numbers of hundreds of billions of
dollars in increased welfare that comes
essentially from having access to
somewhat cheaper products from someplace
that we weren't getting them before but
there's a problem the problem is it
isn't whether you protect or not
everyone protects there are certain
things that we simply don't allow to go
across our borders anyone who suggests
that there are systemic reasons for
protecting anyone who suggests that we
ought to protect in order to allow
certain industries to develop David
Ricardo's old infant industry argument
is now called protectionist and
therefore wrong but if you push these
anti protectionist folks to the wall
they're going to say yes yes yes
we always have to have some basis for
protecting or really doing now is
negotiating the conditions under which
other countries are going to have access
to our markets but at the same time the
corporations that are backing this are
also are also negotiating the conditions
under which they're going to have access
to the cheaper labor in other markets in
which they'd like to produce
to me one of the scariest things about
GATT is the World Trade Organization is
at the name of it that's a group that's
supposed to be created yeah and those
are the people who in secret will be
determining whether there are any
violations of GATT and then the panel
then they will assess the penalties
that'll be the teeth in GATT whether
GATT has always had an enforcement
organization and under that enforcement
organization one country after another
has gone forward and said that
particular policy in that particular
country represents illegal subsidies
therefore we are allowed to pose an imp
unit of tariff on the goods coming from
that country the US has done it more
frequently under the Clinton
administration than it did under Reagan
and Bush in order to protect industries
that seem to be attacked by government
subsidies elsewhere or by other
violations of the earlier varieties of
the GATT agreement and one very vivid
example of the problems this can create
for us comes in terms of the
institutions that GATT has for
protecting people against pesticide and
chemical residues on food that goes back
and forth across the borders of one
country or another get will not allow
you to impose a control on the movement
of food products into your country that
is other than the common standard
worldwide control that's allowed Jim
Hightower here in Texas has been one of
the most outspoken opponents of that
because as he points out in places like
banana products coming across from
Central America from Africa from Asia
into the United States the code which is
the common code in terms of the amount
of DDT which will be allowed on bananas
allows 50 times more DDT than we
presently allow coming in to the United
States the US will have to change its
laws to allow that global standard of
DDT on bananas at the startup of GATT
and will then have to lobby with an
organization that is called and if it
sounds arcane it really is it's called a
codex
Leeman tereus oh yes yeah the Codex
Alimentarius from the Latin for
food-related code is based in Rome and
they set the global standards so if you
and I as individuals who want to
organize a grassroots movement to change
the levels of pesticides which are
allowed on products coming into this
country now I have to go to Congress in
order to get that changed we also under
GAAP would have to go one step further
if we can convince the US Congress to
direct the US government then we have to
go over and convince this whole body of
Representatives were around the world
under the Codex Alimentarius including
all of the representatives of the banana
producing countries who are going to say
well wait a second if we don't use DDT
it's going to be more expensive we can't
make a transformation that rapidly and
they will oppose any increase so what we
have at great cost done in this country
in terms of raising our environmental
standards relative to many of the world
standards are going to get beaten down
in terms of the quality of products that
cross the borders and we are to be able
to do anything about it other than
through these cumbersome organizations
which are not elected we have no way of
there absolutely not not another codex
element the Codex Alimentarius is
appointed by get which consists of a
Council of Representatives appointed by
the governments that are participants in
GATT and we have very very little
control over them what kind of
enforcement powers does get have in
theory Gant has tremendous incarceration
disorganization the World Trade
Organization using GATT as a basis in
theory has tremendous powers it can
authorize punitive tariffs or punitive
quotas or the blocking of trade from any
member country if it decides that member
countries is violating the agreement so
if for example euro Honduras and you're
trying as a tiny tiny country in Central
America trying to stimulate the
development of a little textile industry
and you come up with a creative program
for giving low-interest loans
and others support to some cooperatives
or small businesspeople trying to set up
that textile industry Korea a gigantic
textile country or Japan or India can go
to the GATT and say that's a violation
because that's an inappropriate subsidy
we don't care whether they call it a
development program or not we're going
to block Honduran exports of those
textile we're going to call for blocking
under an exports of the to all the
members of yet and so the authority is
ultimately the ability of GATT to block
the exports of a country that is in
disfavor at that particular moment for
its policies to any other member I
understand - maybe it's only with NAFTA
but is AG at all so that they can
actually levy fines on the Treasury of
participating countries that do well in
theory but it never gets to that stage I
probably would never get to that stage
long before they'd be able to levy fines
you'd have countries ripping up their
gap participation agreements and going
off on their own which would be
difficult because the whole world would
be operating on our gas and they would
be outside of this wall that's exactly
right and so the dynamic tension there
is between GATS the heavy-handedness
with which get implements as regulations
at the same time it doesn't want to see
countries pull out but it's the smallest
countries the ones that most desperately
need a little bit of freedom to exercise
some progressive developmental policies
that are going to be most isolated and
have the smallest amount of cloud and
the smallest amount of power the
lightness process like Thailand being
forced to import cigarettes when we
tried to protect their countries their
people's health or even the big ones the
big countries for instance I I forget
which country it is that's protested the
United States the requirement of a
special net so that they don't trap tuna
and not tuna dolphins in the in the
fishing nets I think Japan is
challenging the United States
prohibition of exporting raw timber and
even some corporate US corporations I
understand are going to challenge the
Health System of Canada saying that it's
under fair unfair trade because
they're corporations in Canada don't
have to pay the medical benefits that
the US corporations after there are
others even to one or not there are even
more outrageous decisions that have been
made in Belgium for example the Belgian
Parliament passed a law saying that if
you're going to sell beverages you have
to have a recycling program in place for
the beverage containers if they're glass
beverages the glass bottles they have to
be recycled if they're aluminium they
have to be recycled and that you have to
have a proactive program it isn't just
that you allowed them to recycle you
have to have a program in place the
other countries that were shipping beer
and soda to Belgium sued in the
International Court of Justice of The
Hague under the terms of the GATT
against Belgium saying that was an
unfair restraint on trade for importing
beverages from outside and they were
upheld in Belgium was forced to rescind
that law and to accept the more general
recycling provisions that are accepted
under the terms of GATT that's another
example of the extent to which while
trying to pursue what the supporters of
God are going to call a level playing
field for trade among countries you are
giving up a tremendous amount of your
own ability to control what happens at
your borders and within your borders a
tremendous amount of what you're able to
do in order to help your own development
along the environmental area is an area
that's very important to get because
environmentalists were almost completely
excluded from the negotiation of gas
GATT like NAFTA involved a very elite
secretive group of people meeting in
various points around the world
negotiating cutting deals industry
specific deals with representatives from
the various trade ministries and
commerce ministries of governments that
were participants in it there were
virtually no representatives of
environmental ministries or the
environmental movement and GATT is
probably going to undermine the single
most important push forward for the
environmental movement in terms of a
world trade which is the push to try to
take protectionism in terms of products
crossing the border to levels of
protection with respect
processes let me explain very briefly
right now you can stop the importation
of a banana coming across the border if
you find pesticide or chemical residues
on it beyond u.s. standards after GATT
is signed it'll be only stoppable if it
exceeds the Codex Alimentarius standards
which are often much higher than US
standards whatever higher in the sense
that they would permit more of these
labels originally or emit more the
pesticides to come in a higher quantity
of parts per billion allowed on the
front and the fruit or on the vegetable
what environmentalists have pushed for
is not product requirements because you
can grow broccoli with illegal chemicals
and then wash the hell out of that
broccoli and get most of those chemicals
off and the inspection system is so bad
that a lot of it will go through in the
event they want process requirements if
you the environmental community
worldwide wants us to change trade laws
so that if you use an illegal
environmentally damaging process in
Mexico in Thailand in Colorado in
outside of Moscow wherever it might be
if you use a process which is found to
be environmentally damaging that
products you should be able to ban
because it is hurting the global
environment in the process of making
something cheaper as it goes across the
border this would mean global inspection
of environmental processes at the plant
level which in fact is a very important
goal of environmental movement yet as it
stands right now would eliminate any
possibility of process restrictions on
the conditions that you could legally
use for borrowing the importation of
goods into the United States or any
other can't remember you know my what I
see and all of this is a well I started
to say subtle I guess maybe it's not
quite so subtle lease isn't quite so
abrupt but it's really an international
revolution of of people from the
international power structure which is
basically economic in nature taking the
ability of people to have any democratic
control whether state local or national
and taking it all putting in
international bodies we have had the
International Monetary Fund and the
World Bank but now all of these things
like NAFTA and then with GATT all these
decisions will supersede anything at the
Democratic level in any country and then
you also see efforts by these same
people to beef up the United Nations
give the United Nations taxing authority
give the United Nations its own army of
course the UN is a very undemocratic
organization too so it looks like slowly
all of these Democratic games not just
in political but environmental and
health and everything that we've had we
fought for for centuries it's all being
taken away from us and people don't even
realize and I think what's even more
dangerous I think you're fundamentally
right what's even more dangerous is we
think we have greater democratic control
over our local communities over over
state and local governments and we
struggle for better Democratic control
over our national governments but
they're becoming increasingly irrelevant
to the real economic decisions that
shape the quality of our life it's these
global institutions that most will
determine much that has to do with the
quality of our life if GATT goes through
corporations will have better
opportunities than ever to move their
production to that place where they can
produce at the very lowest wages with
the very smallest amount of
environmental regulation and they will
be guaranteed under the terms of GATT
access to the markets in all the rest of
the world it is something which
threatens much of which we have been
what we have been able to pull together
as a social contract in this nation with
respect to environmental controls
minimum wages protection of workers
keeping children out of factories the
conditions under which people are able
to work on in dangerous occupations all
of this is being undermined not by a
choice that we're making but by our
national acceptance of a set of
international standards that are
dramatically lower than our own and
against which we will not be able to
protect ourselves any longer because as
soon as we try to say gee we don't like
the environmental conditions in that
Thai factory where they're producing
those good
which are being shipped into the United
States with very very limited exceptions
prison labor child labor and a couple of
other very minor exceptions slave labor
we're not gonna be able to block them
we're not going to be able to bar them
and we're going to be left with this
illusion that now we have access to
cheaper goods but we will have access to
cheaper goods and the people who are
producing them are going to be suffering
the consequences of our having allowed
this global system to be created over
which we have less control than we ever
have and against we had which we have
far less recourse than we have right now
with respect to most of the processes
that affect our lives